so this manual this manual for learning
the basic features of reading the arabic
language for quranic use
is one of the most accessible manuals
that i've actually ever seen
it's what we have on the market
unfortunately at the moment is
is a range of inaccessible manuals which
we can't actually
doesn't have the scaffolding that is
required in order to get
maneuver someone from a stage where they
don't know how to read to a stage where
they can actually feel comfortable
reading
this is one of those manuals which is
extremely accessible
is carefully paced structured and
it has all these kinds of features once
again pedagogical
features which will bring people from a
stage where they don't know things
to being able to read the quran
how are you guys doing i'm here joined
with the beast the daoa beast
he is a man who has created a legacy for
himself
even though he doesn't like to be in
front of the camera zeeshan
[Laughter]
you know that never gets old yeah yeah
how's it going
all right so basically i've always
wanted to do a response to this guy
right
this guy ken ham who is a young age
creationist and
just to give people a background as to
what young age creationism is
it's a group of protestants for the most
part right who believe that the universe
is 6 000 years old based on the
accounts of genesis chapter 5 and
because of other things
for example what church fathers have
said majority of which probably would
concur with that view
and many of the kind of scholars of
christianity
throughout the reform period etc so they
have a strong case from their own
paradigm in fact they have probably
the winning case from their own paradigm
but
what what that that entails believing
that the universe is six thousand years
is uh denial of certain things which we
may think
are undeniable so let's i wanted to look
at today what he thinks about dinosaurs
okay interesting dinosaurs well dinosaur
quite million years old oh
oh it can't be sorry my bad
six i mean six thousand years old five
thousand five hundred fifty what
really happened to the dinosaurs
many people are perplexed by the topic
of dinosaurs where did they come from
when did they live what happened to them
you see when you dig up a dinosaur
skeleton
it doesn't come with a label attached
saying hi i'm 65 million years old and
this is what happened to me
a skeleton in relation to the past so
where did dinosaurs come from
what happened to them when did they live
i want to show you that when you take
god at his word
in the book of genesis that we can
explain dinosaurs and
observational science actually confirms
that explanation based upon the bible
so but by the way um he
redefines everything right so when he
talks about observational science he's
talking about what we observe
he he he denies the fact that any
inference can be made from science
so for him he he writes this in his book
he's written a book on this
and he talks about he's got his own kind
of categorization chem
kem ham does the thing is to be honest
it's not like there's no scope
in christianity for saying that the yom
because the word yom is actually used in
the quran
and also used in the genesis account as
well it's exactly the same word in
hebrew as yom
could mean a long period of time but for
them it's not that
it's it's genesis chapter 5 right which
talks about because what
if you look at genesis chapter 5 you'll
see it's like adam
and then his son was this person and
then it's a genealogy and they have
dates
and then i have dates like each so it's
like every person is like 130 years
between the first person 100 and
whatever he is
and so they add it up so this person
called asha and bishop asha
famously he he found out when the
beginning of the world was and so on so
this is where he's coming from
and it's true to say the vast majority
if not i think all of them except for
the
alexandrian school of church fathers
believed uh
would concur with this uh if not they
didn't have anything to say about it but
the reformist kind of theologians and
stuff they believe in that as well so
6 000 year old thing it might seem
trivial to us now we're having a laugh
but this was i would say the vast
majority opinion
in christendom so it's orthodox belief
it's an orthodox belief yes
interesting see the bible tells us that
god made
the land animals on day six of creation
and who else was created on day six well
adam and eve
and how long ago was that it's really
interesting because the bible does talk
about
uh the kind of uh day by day creation
everyone knows this
the thing is it's so contradictory like
when you open it's not only is
it's contradictory to the external
reality or archaeological or
paleontological evidence yeah
but it's contradictory of itself like
for example in the bible it says that
day and night were created on the first
day
and that on day four yeah okay uh on day
four the luminaries were created so the
sun and
all these kinds of things were created
right and so the question would be how
can you have night and day without the
sun
right how can you have and then you
talked about the vegetation right
vegetation
and that was created with the vegetation
on in genesis chapter 1 verse 11
that was created on uh on the fourth day
i think it was or
whatever third day of mountain right but
then in genesis chapter two verse five
no plant has sprung up yet yeah so
you have contradictions within and so
much so the origin of alexandria who is
an allegorist
for the most part he spiritualized the
meanings of the text he looked at me and
said what man of intelligence
i'm gonna put these references in the
comment section below what man of
intelligence
would believe that the luminaries were
created on the fourth day and that the
night and they were creating the first
day so you have internal contradictions
yes
okay and then you have external problems
as well so this has led these kinds of
people
to just stick to their guns and say it
must be science that's wrong
okay i must be history that's wrong it
must be paleontology that's wrong it
must be archaeology that's wrong all of
those things are right
and we are right that's interesting from
i think there's a little bit of credit
needs to be given because they didn't
feel
insecure they said no the bible is i do
agree yeah however
the fact that you accept bible to be
true yes shows that the bible is not
true
right does that make sense so for
example they're saying look we're not
going to go and be like changing words
god's word
we're going to stick to it but the fact
that you stick to it shows that it's not
the word
right right it's interesting uh paradox
yeah it is interesting yeah well when
you add up all the dates in the bible
about 6 000 years
so taking guided his word in genesis
dinosaurs lived beside people
about 6 000 years ago and they were
vegetarian to start with genesis chapter
1 verse 29
tells us that all the animals are
vegetarian but then adams
can we just say one more thing bro about
this guy yeah answers in genesis is one
of the most
well-funded organizations in the united
states of america yeah okay
when i looked at the numbers i think the
turnover was something like 100 million
charity
100 million that's one-tenth of a
billion pounds
no there's no dour organization on the
face of the earth which comes
close to that comes close to that and
these guys have a museum
okay they have a museum where they
depict adam and eve and
uh and you know the dinosaurs yeah side
by side
these kinds of things bro but you know
we can watch a little bit more of this
what can we say because we were just
having a conversation about this before
the show
yeah yeah you know but christianity is
based on the resurrection isn't it
and if you believe in the resurrection
it's a historical event yes
so really if you don't believe in it
you're doomed to hell fire you have that
it's a mainstream christian belief
right so if you're if you're if you're
doomed to hell fire for
not believing in a historical event yeah
if you have skepticism think of it this
way
if you have skepticism towards a
historical event which in this case is
the resurrection
and if you employ the same skepticism to
the date of 6 000 years
one of one of those types of historical
skepticism will take you to hell
in the case of uh believing that the
universe is six thousand years that's
not a problem
but believing that having historical
skepticism of the resurrection
that one will take you to hell yeah
exactly so basically you have to be
certain as hell
of the resurrection or you go hell you
know you know
the truth is that yeah you have to be
certain as hell yeah if you're not
certain as hell yeah
you go in hell
that's what it is and then when it comes
to this yeah um
and and the thing is you know it's it
just shows you the contradiction you
know
hypocrisy yes you know and to be honest
you know some people come to us we speak
to people in the park in the speakers
one and they come to us and say
you know the resurrection is for certain
yes would you say from your experience
dealing with people that that could be
the central argument for the veracity of
christianity
they want to proof christianity through
the resurrection yeah exactly if that's
their central argument it's a historical
argument right yeah yeah so okay on the
one hand we can be
we can't be skeptical when it comes to
these reports contradictory reports in
the new testament
about the resurrection which by the way
on his historical analysis
methodological naturalism is uh supreme
so we can't even say that supernatural
things happen
okay if we wanted to be completely you
know in line with secular reasoning
which we're not to be
we can give it to them no problem but at
the end of the day
we can't be skeptical of the
resurrection yeah but you can be
skeptical to the entire enterprise of
archaeology and the entire enterprise of
paleontology
the entire enterprise of history and one
of those types of skepticism
will lead you in an internal doom and
burning in the hellfire yeah and the
other one won't yeah exactly and that's
what
that's beautiful you know about islam
hamdulillah you know then they are
allah doesn't uh test like christianity
you deny the resurrection it's finished
for you
islam allah says we do not punish a
nation until we send the messenger
you know islam is very unique in that
subhanallah that no one will be
punished unless they because it's the
mercy of god and i'll be honest with you
a lot of people come to me
with a resurrection thing and they're
very certain about it and then the quran
came down
600 years later and change the whole
narrative and to me
in a nutshell if the quran is the word
of god and who knows best history but
god
you know so if the quran is a word of
god and allah is saying that
jesus peace be upon him was not killed
not crucified but allah saved him
i'm going to go with that you know so if
there's christians watching this
you know at the end of the day if you're
going to put your trust in this
you know if you're going to not deny the
resurrection there is absolute hypocrisy
with the whole genesis
account so to us is if you read the book
of the quran
and you if you believe it to be god and
there's evidences that prove that you've
done reading books
you've released a book um i've got a
booklet which i'm gonna put it on the
description box as well for the
evidences for the truth of islam exactly
so then who knows best history but god
and if god is telling you
jesus was not killed nor was he
crucified i'm sorry i'm taking that to
account
rather than this the whole bible
you know what you said that i think
that's right it's a good point yeah it
was good to end with this as well
yeah that what you could say you can
make the argument if
if we have to believe in the
resurrection to be christians yes
so really christianity is based on
historical event yeah whereas the
difference between christianity and
islam from that perspective
is that islam is based on a concept and
the concept is submission to one god
yes submission worship one god yeah
right
and that i think is the main difference
between the two religions yeah
exactly so yeah brother and sister you
know if you're watching as a christian
uh there's books i'm sure you're gonna
put in the link which you can get um and
you know
and read that and see for yourself uh
and like i said before guys the best
person to know history and what really
happened to jesus peace be upon him
if you go to the bible you you're a bit
of it you're a dilemma from all angles
yeah is true if i read if i reject the
resurrection which i do
i'm doomed to hell and it's based on
accounts which are you know mark matthew
their stories contradict each other so
guys
if the word if the quran is a word of
god and god knows
history which he does he's the unknowing
go and find out really what happened to
jesus peace be upon him
and instead of worshiping him worship
the one who created him and that's it
pleasure